and you know this this last question
it's
it's not really a question well it it
look I get a lot of awesome emails
and I get emails from people that have
completely turned
their lives around they've they've lost
weight if they need to lose weight or
they've gained weight because they need
to gain weight or they've gotten
promoted or they've become a better
parent
or they've become a better spouse or
they become a better kid yeah
and I get emails from people that have
quit their addictions or they've or
they've overcome their fear
and I'll tell you what I get
letters and and packages and notes about
all this kind of stuff and it's awesome
I get I get people send me books
for the podcast and and pictures and
drawings and
and Military
memorabilia or unit patches and coins
from you know police departments and
fire departments and and military units
it's just
it's awesome
and and I'm
I'm so thankful for all that feedback
and it it drives me
that feedback that I get drives me to
work hard and keep
pushing
to do this to the best of my ability and
try and get better at it
but
you know I I hear from people that have
used the podcast and the discipline and
the the the
mindset of looking at things
that are problematic as being good
I hear from people that have used those
things to overcome
you know dark patches yeah in their
lives you know whether it's depression
or anxiety or even like full-fledged
despair
and again when you hear from people that
are turned that corner that's
just incredibly rewarding
to know that there's you know there's
people out there that are really
changing for the better and turning
their lives from
negative
to positive
it's
unbelievably
rewarding
but I also get
some other emails and I get some other
messages
from people that haven't been able
to dig out of that hole to overcome that
that despair
I I hear from people sometimes that feel
there's nowhere nowhere else to go
there's no way out
and they don't have any more options
and they are considering
taking the only way out that they can
see and that is they want to take their
own life
and
to anybody out there that's in that
place
you know
I don't really know what exactly to tell
you
but I can kind of tell you
what I think
I think no
I think no I think don't save that last
bullet for yourself
don't save it for yourself you Lock and
Load that last bullet
and you shoot it at your enemy
and when you're out of bullets get out
your knife and attack with that
and if you lose your knife you grab
your enemy by the throat and you keep
fighting
and you keep fighting and you keep
fighting and you keep fighting no matter
what
and you never quit
you never never quit
and if you feel like your life is in a
place where you can't get any lower
and you don't think
you can find any way out
because that means the ultimate
challenge
is ahead of you it means you can only go
up
and it also means
that things are going to be tough
things are going to be
tougher than anything you can imagine
but
that storm that you're in from from your
perspective
it seems like that storm is enveloping
the whole world
but I'm telling you it is not
the storm that you're in it is hard to
see out of that storm it's hard to see
past it it seems like the storm
it seems like the storm is everything
but the storm is not everything
and it won't last forever
you can get out of the storm and you
will get out of the storm and when you
get out
you're going to see the sun
again
but right now
you're being tried
you're being forged you're being tested
by fire and by pain
that's the test
don't fail the test
don't fail the test don't give in don't
quit
don't ever quit
fight on
fight through the storm
fight through the pain and come out the
other side stronger
and tougher
and better
a fighter
a survivor
a winner
Victorious
and
free from that storm
free from the darkness
free